l'icône hotech océan indien une autre
passerelle entre la réunion et mahdhah
premier test grandeur nature fin juillet
jean-jacques john et angus and could
professeur de français du lycée
philibert tsiranana ma job à mission à
la réunion comme un cadreur des élèves
lauréats comme compétitions nationales
de français à madagascar
les élèves du lycée où je me trouve et
le récompenser ce séjour de 11 jours à
l'arrivée parmi les programmes de ces
quinze jours il y avait cette visite du
dico knotek où toutes tailles et ya
découvert à découvrir et on a tout
découvert
et face aux élus
dans site internet quand on voit des
images des photos intéressant d histoire
des arts bon il faut consulter parce que
c'est une genre d'échangés de culture au
delà de l'échangé des cultures et de la
soif de savoir et de découvrir un voyage
dans l'espace et surtout dans le temps à
la recherche de ses racines et de son
avenir et c'est pour moi quelque chose
de très important parce quelle histoire
c'est tout c'est tout pour nous c'est
vrai la tte la technologie s'est elle
bien mais aussi il faut aussi connaître
et se doit elle présente un peu
madagascar depuis la ville de malaga est
venu ici l icône aussi pour admirer à
plein des offres numériques et
historique la région et nous sommes
vraiment ravis parce que
ça vous permet de revivre l'histoire
donc vraiment donner vie à l'ispa parce
que maintenant on a envie de confort
géorgie le délai est attribué mais aussi
d'être le témoin de la nouvelle
génération et qui est le plus
intéressant c'est qu'on nous a montré
quelque chose auquel nous allons avoir
accès via internet et non seulement nous
avons accès mais notre pays occupe aussi
une place assez importante à chieti
collègues du sahara nour à vigo en sus
points biko notait qu il eut du plus
belle passerelle dans l'histoire
cliff grand chef de projet madagascar
appui enseignements du en français mais
il sert l'éducation nationale malgache
et donc je représente ici l'ambassade de
france
j'ai accompagné de groupes de jeunes
lauréats de la compétition nationale de
france qui est un projet de partenariat
entre l'ambassade de france à madagascar
le ministère d'éducation nationale
malgache le conseil général de la
réunion
la mairie de saint denis et air austral
ils vont visiter l'île vont visiter
beaucoup de sites
nous on verrait d'une peine ils vont
vivre une belle expérience et on espère
que de retour à madagascar y serons
capables de communiquer tout leur
enthousiasme tout ce qu'ils auront
appris auprès de leurs collègues de
leurs camarades du lycée philibert
tsiranana de mach 1 4 grâce à l'icône
hotech maintenant
je suis impatient de visiter les musées
pour voir les oeuvres qu'ils ont
présentés c'est très enrichissant au
niveau culture alors sans armement peu
plus curieux pour connaître la culture
de la réunion et d'ailleurs nous sommes
très bien accueillis
merci